[Music]
[Music]
we start with what was arguably the
biggest moment at last night's met gala
and ms kardashian right here
kim kardashian hitting those famous
steps in marilyn monroe's 60 year old
4.8 million dollar dress with boyfriend
pete davidson looking so good kim kay
how are you feeling in this special
dress tonight kim
nervous i'd say so uh yeah i'd be
nervous too the dress which marilyn wore
the night she serenaded president john f
kennedy on his 45th birthday is
literally dripping in hand-sewn crystals
by costume designer jean-louis 6 000 to
be exact now it was loaned to kim by
ripley's believe it or not museum in
orlando marking get this the first time
it's left it's dark temperature and
humidity controlled vault since being
purchased by the museum back in 2016. no
one besides kim and miss monroe have
worn the dress kim told vogue it
actually didn't fit the first time she
tried it on forcing her to follow a
strict three-week diet which included
running on the treadmill and a sauna
suit twice a day and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to
be able to fit this but i it was such a
challenge it was like a role right i was
determined yeah i was determined to win
it you put your mind to something
there's no you were like eating tomatoes
i don't think they believe me i don't
think they believed that i was going to
do it we do now she did it you know
paparazzi caught kim in orlando for her
final fitting last week which sparked
the initial rumors that she'd be donning
what she calls the original naked dress
mr president
the late marilyn monroe
unlike the late actress kim only wore
the sheer number for a matter of minutes
just long enough to make her
well-rehearsed grand entrance up the
steps
for the rest of the night she wore a
replica she wasn't taking any chances on
that one as for how the reality star
achieved the late actresses look well
she spent all day sunday bleaching her
hair and compared to the getting ready
process to a highly sophisticated
military operation you know she has to
get dressed in like a secret dressing
room
yeah after the met kim celebrated with
what else carbs and pizza
you guys i haven't had carbs
or sugar in almost a month
definitely three weeks this
pizza
i'm so excited
and we had some questions about kim and
pete for mama bear kris jenner who
showed up on the red carpet channeling
jackie o in oscar de la renta the look
mirrored the former first lady's state
dinner look from 1961. whoever has it
that pete has a new little tattoo that
he's acquired on his neck i don't know
what do you think of mr paint dave i
think he's great
chris was also relieved after her
family's victory over blac chyna just
hours earlier
chris told us that she had fun getting
ready with her daughters a first for the
whole fam and the first met gala ever
for chloe and courtney chloe showed out
in custom gold mosquino that has more
than 540 000 hand sewn glass beads and
she confessed some nerves on twitter
saying she almost had a heart attack on
the carpet court and fiance travis
parker looked calm giving us their
signature pda photo bombing sierra in
the process in matching tom brown
menswear
she looks amazing
my baby looks amazing both look so good
so courtney when you heard that the
theme was gilded glamour like what did
that mean to you
i honestly didn't really think about it
i feel like this is like it and then
mine's like falling like dripping off of
him maybe she didn't think about it
because she's got her mind on another
look coming up a source tells e.t
courtney is already bouncing wedding
dress ideas off her sisters and tell us
you're ready to get married without
telling us you're ready to get married
insert baby sis kylie she arrived
without travis scott in what looked like
a wedding gown complete with a veil and
ball cap a nod to her friend and late
designer virgil abloh
you know the met gala meant day to night
for a lot of celebrity couples blake
lively and ryan reynolds were co-chairs
of the event and had our jaws fully on
the floor check out blake's stunning
versace gown dripping in sequins and
crystals inspired by nyc's classic
architecture and your eyes aren't
playing tricks on you the dress it
changed colors but no one was more
impressed than ryan he's a smitten kid
he just turned his head
it's quite heavy meanwhile sophie turner
and joe jonas are giving us another
reason to believe they're ready for baby
number two sophie cradling her bump as
they showed up matching in black and
white louis vuitton now they haven't
made an official announcement but fans
are convinced another bundle of joy is
on the way their gorgeous ensembles gave
us serious adams family vibes and it
wouldn't be the first time remember
their halloween costumes from 2018
moving on to brooklyn beckham and nikola
peltz who made their red carpet debut as
man and wife nicola was a real-life
barbie doll rocking hot pink valentino
brooklyn booked the tuxedo trend and
wore a cream-colored suit and he must
have paid attention in husband training
because look at this he held her purse
for the after party now i wonder if this
future hubby took notes i'm talking
about this guy right here who early in
the evening
proposed to laurie cuppo the
commissioner of new york city cultural
affairs and y'all she said yes i didn't
know it was going to happen tonight
we've been talking about it we've been
through so much and this is such an
honor and this is such a blessing oh i
love love speaking of gabrielle union
and dwyane wade they understood the
assignment looking all sorts of sexy
gabrielle slayed in a silver versace
gown with a plunging neckline while
d-wade showed some skin too
sir my wife told me to leave my shirt in
the car well now another star who went
topless cara delevingne she revealed
gold body paint jewelry and pasties
after removing the coat of her dior hook
couture suit
i just thought it was a time that we
needed to you know do things a little
differently
another trend though men with manicures
anderson pack showed off his to et's
cameras
let me see these nails yes it doesn't
stop oh my god even my fingertips are
ready for the for the night so ready see
that i used to shop at burlington coat
factory all my life did you now i'm
gucci from head to toe shawn mendes
rocked hand-painted gel nails 2 with the
tommy hilfiger flag but broadway star
ben platt took it a step further with a
full acrylic set
we caught ben in this masculine corset
trend too here he is in a black silk
from christian cowan you know lenny
kravitz he got the memo too combining
lace leather and a cape thing he looks
good he switched into this snakeskin
number though for his performance inside
[Music]
next on the trend list gilded gown with
built in hoods post star mj rodriguez
hit the steps in this gold sequin
moschino dress and e.t got ready with
janelle monae what did you enjoy most
about the process leading up to the
carpet
just feeling sensual i'm in a movie
right
now there's comedian amy schumer who
arrived with her crew which included
venus williams in all black chloe
sunglasses included turns out the vibe
was a collaborative effort
gabriella's vision and she wanted us to
look like very powerful women and i
think that we do and then amy came up
with the glasses so she's a director of
it
and you know what we love this look on
emma stone and fun fact this is at least
the second time she's worn this white
louis vuitton dress the first time it
was at the after party of her super
secret wedding to dave mccary back in
2020. it was also a big night for the
cast of euphoria who actually made their
met gala debut mod apatow understood the
assignment channeling old hollywood
glamour wearing a jeweled flapper styled
mew gown complete with a finger wave and
moody makeup and as you can tell this
first timer just couldn't contain her
excitement meanwhile mod's co-star
sydney sweeney looked like a princess in
tory burch and channeled princess
diaries in her behind-the-scenes
transformation only paulo
can take this
and this
and give you a princess
speaking of transformations sydney
stunned on the steps at the met when she
revealed underneath that long train was
a mini dress
excuse us
i cannot get over that okay what's
better than one dress two at the met
she's left me speechless
listen jacob elodie also brought a
little sparkle to the carpet he rocked a
custom burberry suit hand embroidered
with crystal embellishments so where was
india well she revealed to press last
week that she was busy working
but another cast gracing the met gala
together the folks behind the upcoming
elvis biopic austin butler who will play
the king in the baslerman film arrived
with priscilla presley but to get this
austin narrowly missed a run-in with his
ex vanessa hudgins who was busy hosting
the met gala live stream for vogue
instead he made his red carpet debut
with girlfriend kaia gerber meanwhile
casey musgraves also hit the met for the
first time with her man cole schaefer
they sealed their first official
appearance together with none other than
a kiss casey by the way will be featured
on the elvis soundtrack inside she
performed a cover of i can't help
falling in love
from a country queen to our pop
princesses like lizzo who turned up the
tempo get it on the red carpet i got it
the 34 year old singer put on a show
playing her flute in between poses the
singer donned a black tom brown corset
dress with an embroidered oversized coat
a look that took 22 thousand hours of
work and if you look closely she's got
corkscrew nails okay we're talking
details here folks and she was living it
up inside too taking selfies with sizza
billy eilish and the hadith sisters also
nicki minaj just to name a few meanwhile
looking lovely in lavender olivia
rodrigo posed for some pics with one of
her idols gwen stefani who was rocking a
neon two-piece verawang look which is
also the same designer behind her
wedding dress from last summer gwen was
missing her plus one hobie blake shelton
but he wasn't far from her mind it was
fun to be out in new york and it was
glamorous and wow
and now i'm gonna go
see my husband also did you catch gwen's
makeup and her pop of blue eyeliner she
did her own glam using her new beauty
line now noticeably absent at the event
she usually owns rihanna a source tells
e.t rereed didn't make it because she's
due to give birth soon and is limiting
travel but y'all she was there in spirit
vogue posted this video showing off a
marvel statue of the singer's pregnant
physique inside the museum
you